hello there a blog post
controversially entitled please commit
more blatant academic fraud
has been making waves in the machine
learning slash ai community
on twitter and reddit especially because
it is the cry of a fellow phd
student you know not a renowned
professor or anything
miss coffee bean proposed to give this
blog post a read
and to comment on it in this video so
what is this all about
the blog post starts directly with
mentioning what even triggered its
writing
it is this viewpoint by a renowned
personality in the machine learning
community professor michael
l littman this piece is reporting about
the method of cheating the peer review
called collusion rings and bear with
miss coffee bean because we know that
you know that peer review is broken
but this is like organized fraud it's
the collusion ring mafia breaking the
already broken review system okay so
what's the deal
how does this work pay close attention
because this is so
intricate that miss coffee bean honestly
wonders how somebody can even come
up with this well it's smart people
working
in ai after all the scheme works like
this
first a group of colluding authors
you're not a native english speaker miss
coffee bean are you
collusion secret or illegal cooperation
or
conspiracy in order to deceive others
so we're on that level now okay so a
group of colluding authors
writes and submits papers to a
conference that's
something even non-crooked authors would
do but then they share amongst
themselves the title of the papers which
is against the rules because it ruins
anonymity in peer-reviewing
then these colluders hide their conflict
of interest
so they hide anything that could tell a
meta reviewer that they
might know the other authors how well
with duplicate accounts
and interestingly enough there was no
way to tell these are fake accounts
well not really not in a field growing
and growing
like machine learning does currently
exponentially
so the collusion ring fellowship bids
for the papers
which means that in the phase where the
reviewers can tell which papers they
would like to review
they choose the papers from their
collusion ring
fellowship and hopefully they get the
papers of their fellows
write positive reviews to them and even
lobby through back channels to change
the opinions of other reviewers or
send threats if others feel like
something is fishy
wow and the most crazy part is this
scheme seemed to work in this discovered
case
but who knows how many cases go
undetected
the viewpoint piece is not disclosing
specific details
just to respect the fraudulent
researchers and not disclose information
that might identify them oh
it's anonymous peer review after all but
thinking how
important conference acceptances are for
anyone and especially for phd students
who do not have the safety of a
professorship or tenure and need to find
the next job after their phd
it's no wonder it hit jacob buckman who
is a phd student
so badly that it motivated him to write
this blog post which we finally come to
discuss right now
independently on whether you agree with
him or not you are free to form
your own opinions but we think we can
all agree that this is a very grim
viewpoint adopted here his main point is
that
this example highlighted by professor
littman
might be one of the worst cases of
fraud but that there is a more mundane
and day-to-day fraud that is happening
regularly but if the day-to-day fraud
would be more blatant
like the fellowship of the collusion
rings fraud
we saw earlier a change in the fields
organization might come sooner because
then everybody would see how wrong
everything
is and fight for a change so what
exactly is wrong in machine learning
example of this day-to-day fraud are
beside
trying that shiny new algorithm out on a
couple dozen
seeds and then only reporting the best
few well
that's happening for sure running a big
hyper parameter sweep
on your proposed approach but using the
defaults for the baseline who
even spends so much time tuning the
baselines and
some of the baselines are not even
tunable because
the code was not released or it's not
working for some reason
cherry-picking examples where your model
looks good or
cherry picking whole data sets to test
on where you've confirmed your model's
advantage
making up new problem settings new data
sets new objectives in order to claim
victory on an
empty playing field well this one is a
little against
the goal of research and has been
discussed on twitter
and miss coffeebean also thinks it's a
little unfair because even if sometimes
you don't see
the impact of a new problem or
application there are people
who genuinely need that it's not
necessarily that
an author is creating a problem just for
the sake of having one
okay then proclaiming that your work is
a promising first step in your
introduction despite being fully aware
that nobody
will ever build on it submitting a paper
to a conference because it's got a
decent shot at acceptance and you don't
want the time you spent on it to go to
waste
even though you've since realized that
the core ideas aren't quite correct
this last point is very heavily weighing
on
phd students with limited time to get to
hold on to something
especially if things are not going so
well there's
a lot of pressure to still make a
publication out of that
this is why miss coffee bean salutes
initiatives that
highlight negative results in the field
like this one here
making it unnecessary to hide that
results are bad and to mask them as
actually
good okay so these are the problems and
jacob bachmann miss coffee bean is this
how the name is
really pronounced so jacob writes that
the
even bigger problem is that these points
are subtle
and easy to dismiss by saying something
like the hyper parameters were just
forgotten or that something is just a
bug
therefore nobody can propose hard
punishments for this and miss coffee
beans rule of cheating
says that if one does it the next does
it
until most of people do it just to keep
up with everybody who is cheating
already okay but the next point in the
post is saying that everybody is
complicit because nobody acknowledges
the existence of this
subtle fraud and there are some reasons
to this especially those people
benefiting from the current state of
affairs
do not want a new organization of things
that's easy to understand
but this point falls rather short in the
blog post miss coffee bean doesn't it
because this point implies a little that
everybody knows about these problems but
do they here we might have to split
between people who do know and people
who don't
there are some examples of people who
don't my
experience from teaching students at my
university is that people
are not born knowing about these
problems but they have to learn about
them
one by one especially at bachelors and
even master's level
it is very common that research papers
are read like the bible
things in it might be true if it stands
in a paper
it was accepted at a conference somebody
even formatted it nicely with latex
critical thinking is something that one
has to learn
another group of people who do not know
about the problems
but have critical thinking are
experienced researchers
critical thinking applies only to their
fields
of expertise because on some topics they
just don't know
enough to even think critically and you
know if you're just visiting a field or
a topic you
will also not invest the time necessary
to learn all things you're just
passing by okay but even if miss coffee
bean does not agree with distributing
the blame
so widely she does agree that there are
not many people doing something
effectively about
these problems even if there are some
attempts at it some attempts were
highlighted in this tweet by anna rogers
linked in the description below
check it out but what to do about these
problems in the proposal of this blog
post well the proposal is to make
academic fraud blatant
visible to everyone but especially
unacceptable so that one
cannot merely stand aside doing nothing
about it
make blatant fraud aggressive fraud form
more collusion rings like the ones we
have seen in the beginning
this is the grim call of a phd student
and
this has to be taken seriously he even
makes an analogy to
chemotherapy unpleasant but effective
even if
it destroys the field entirely so miss
coffee beans question
is do we want this to happen to the
machine learning community do we want to
kill it to hope it rises again but
without all problems from before
well as someone originally from a
country that has recently
seen this kind of treatment in a bloody
revolution but where at the end all the
old problems came back
in a slightly different form this time
just
dressed as capitalism instead of
socialism
i'm very distrustful that even if
everybody would follow this advice this
would really cure the problems
because who would follow this advice who
would volunteer to make these blatant
frauds anyone willing to put their
academic integrity on the line
no anyone do not get us wrong here
i as a fellow phd student love the
revolutionary angry tone of this blog
post
i feel with it it is great that these
topics come up with a discussion and
here
we cheer for jacob who wrote it
but miss coffee bean takes me down from
my angry
phd frustrations and tells me to think
more constructively and propose a
solution that not
only has a chance to work but one that
people are even
willing to apply in the first place so
here it is the long-awaited solution to
all problems in machine learning
publications reviewing and the collusion
ring cancer
are you ready
sorry the broadcast was interrupted
just like during the romanian revolution
in 1989
that's the reference probably not many
viewers will get sorry
okay miss coffee bean has three
proposals they are not fully fleshed out
that might possibly become a future
video
i don't know here they are in their
current form the first thing is
education
as previously said from my teaching
experience there is a lot of work needed
to teach
students and people in general that just
because something is written
in a conference format or is i don't
know in a
nice video does not make it true
critical thinking also useful for
reviewing
must be learned and practiced not taken
for granted
and the best thing that could happen out
of this is that critically
thinking students will take over when
the dinosaurs conducting signs badly
will disappear we know it's a long time
investment
nobody likes these the second proposal
is
discussion putting these issues into the
public view and to everyone's discussion
exactly
like this post does miss coffee bean
loves how it highlights these subtle
problems and puts them into broad
daylight for people all around the world
to discuss about this
on twitter or reddit and the final idea
is in-depth and independent science
journalism in machine learning
writers bloggers or even people with
youtube channels to get
monthly a random subset of all new
publications to critically assess
publicly review and simultaneously
communicate to non-experts what the
field is
up to the upside even if not all
publications from that month will fall
into this random selective
lottery there is a chance that when an
author publishes a paper
that paper will be randomly chosen for
the public review process
it's enough of an incentive for the
authors to make their paper
waterproof especially knowing that a
well-known
critic will say something about your
paper
of course one has to take care that
these public reviewers do not have any
conflict of interest or that they have
to be afraid that their own papers would
get negative reviews so
what miss coffee bean is imagining is
this as a full-time
job for them like literary critics for
novels or for
poetry and of course these journalists
reviewers should be well paid
perhaps by someone with a lot of money
caring for a healthy
and diverse field to create perhaps a
common font
where any machine learning benefactor
could
contribute to what do you think of this
of course these are just some
suggestions miss coffee being thought of
just now so let's discuss write in the
comments
tweet or perhaps write a position paper
for the next conference
how should we improve the state of
publication in ai
perhaps without killing it first okay so
tell us what you do think miss coffee
bean will
devour your comments even if the state
of machine learning academia is not
healthy
we hope you are stay safe
you